[Musik]
atemschutzmasken stadt kleidung genäht
von ehrenamtlichen in heimarbeit
desinfektionsmittel stadt himbeergeist
eine schwäbische brennerei überbrückt
engpässe in krankenhausapotheken und
startmenü á la carte bereiten hamburger
köche kostenlos essen für ärzte
feuerwehrleute und supermarktangestellte
zu da sind nur ein paar beispiele für
die positiven seiten der korona krise
das engagement das gerade entsteht und
damit herzlich willkommen zu diesem zdf
spezial die korona pandemie bedeutet
nicht nur einschränkungen und verzicht
ganz im gegenteil viele menschen werden
aktiv denken um und versuchen in der
krise zu helfen und zusammenzuhalten im
privaten stichwort nachbarschaftshilfe
aber auch in der arbeitswelt die krise
schafft neue aufgaben
das gilt auch für die bundeswehr
ordnungsämter oder die polizei die sich
jetzt immer mehr auf den kampf gegen das
virus konzentriert sarah schon berichtet
polizeikontrolle am weiherring in
dortmund für die insassen dieses pkw es
heißt es jetzt erst mal anhalten
die beiden müssen den beamten plausibel
erklären können warum sie zusammen
unterwegs sind
eigentlich will die polizei mit dem
kontrollpunkt hier gegen raser vorgehen
die meinen dass sie auf den leeren
straßen mal so richtig gas geben können
immer wieder fallen den beamten dabei
auf personen auf die nicht zusammen in
einem auto sitzen dürften da weisen wir
natürlich auf das kontaktverbot hin und
uneinsichtige menschen und die
kontrollieren wie nicht nur sondern wir
stellen deren personalien fest schreiben
eine ordnungswidrigkeitenanzeige und
legen die dann entsprechend der
ordnungsbehörde zur entscheidung vor
in kerpen sind mitarbeiter des
ordnungsamts im einsatz um zu
kontrollieren ob sich die bürger in der
stadt an die strengen kontakt
beschränkungen halten damit sich das
virus nicht weiter verbreiten kann
nicht immer stoßen michael marmot und
seine kollegen dabei auf verständnis es
gibt einige die verstehen hast sie
verstehen auch unsere arbeit aber es
gibt leider leider immer noch menschen
die es einfach nicht verstehen wollen
weil es halt der unsichtbare feind der
unsichtbare feind das ist das corona
virus jede menschenansammlung ist eine
potenzielle gefahr
auf diesem sportplatz soll sich eine
gruppe jugendlicher getroffen haben als
die beamten eintreffen ist aber keiner
mehr zu sehen
so wie es meistens ist katz und maus
spiel wir kommen an und kann als männer
und dann ist plötzlich völlig neue
aufgaben im kampf gegen das virus die
haben auch die soldaten der bundeswehr
überall in deutschland unterstützen sie
die behörden logistisch und medizinisch
hier in saarbrücken haben sie in wenigen
tagen eine drive-in teststation
aufgezogen die ärzte hier sind
zivilisten den reibungslosen ablauf aber
garantieren zwölf soldaten die permanent
vor ort sind also wir stellen hier die
rahmen organisationen sprich
absperrpfosten dann material um diese
testungen hier durchführen zu können
wir stellen des weiteren noch ein
kurierfahrer der dass die abgenommenen
tests ins labor bringt ungewöhnliche
aufgaben für die soldaten in
ungewöhnlichen zeiten und zugeschaltet
ist mir jetzt
bundesverteidigungsministerium annegret
kramp karrenbauer guten abends halogen-
abend in welchen bereichen hilft die
bundeswehr den aktuell im kampf gegen
das corona virus zuerst einmal die
bundeswehr baut eine struktur auf wie
wir sie so noch nie gekannt haben wir
haben ein eigenes einsatzkontingent mit
15.000 soldatinnen und soldaten gebildet
dazu kommen noch einmal 15 tausend
reservisten sie sich bis heute schon
gemeldet haben und wir helfen im moment
auf sehr unterschiedlichen feldern
das eine ist das thema beschaffung der
transport etwa von schutz material
wir sind mit dabei wenn es darum geht
ältere menschen die zurzeit nicht raus
sollen auch zum einkaufen mit zu
versorgen
wir haben uns an der polnischen grenze
um liegen gebliebene und im stau
stehenden autofahrer gekümmert wir sind
im moment sehr sehr aktiv was das thema
fieber ambulanz
abstrich stellen anbelangt unsere
eigenen krankenhäuser bereiten sich gut
vor und natürlich das konnte man am
wochenende sehen auch auf der
europäischen ebene mit den
entsprechenden transporten von intensiv
und schwerst erkrankten
es gibt ja gerade viele anträge auf
amtshilfe können sie da denn immer ja
sagen nein leider nicht es gibt sehr
sehr viele anträge viele beziehen sich
auf schutzausstattung oder auf
medizinisches personal das ist natürlich
der punkt an dem wir genauso begrenzt
sind wie andere zivile einrichtungen
auch aber alles das was wir irgendwie
leisten können das versuchen wir auch
umzusetzen
insbesondere dort wo wir über
fähigkeiten verfügen die so kein anderer
hat wie etwa die möglichkeit in einem
flugzeug sechs intensiv und zu beatmen
die patienten inklusive des
medizinischen personals zu verlegen da
tun wir das das ist im moment
insbesondere unser einsatz
mit blick auf unsere freunde in italien
oder unser einsatz mit blick auf die
französischen nachbarn für einsätze der
bundeswehr im inneren gibt es ja enge
grenzen und sie sind ja auch durchaus
umstritten gerade wenn es um den einsatz
von soldaten als hilfspolizisten geht
ist das in irgendeiner form geplant
wir bewegen uns im moment auf der
grundlage des artikel 35 absatz 1
grundgesetz das ist die klassische
amtshilfe die gibt uns schon viele viele
möglichkeiten um zu helfen
wir planen nicht dass wir die polizei im
inneren ersetzen
wir haben gesagt wenn etwa unserer
eigenen kasernen die zurzeit von
privaten wachdiensten geschützt werden
wenn dieser schutz ausfallen würde wegen
der korona lage dann müssen wir in der
lage sein unsere eigenen einrichtungen
zu schützen
wir werden aber auch bereit und in der
lage etwa kritische infrastruktur
wasserwerke elektrizitätswerke auch bei
der bewachung mit zu unterstützen aber
sind ganz ganz enge grenzen
die rechtliche grundlage ist dass er
eindeutig und auf der bewegen wir uns
und über die brauchen moment nicht
diskutiert zu werden
vielen dank frau kramp karrenbauer für
das gespräch
bitteschön und das interview haben wir
kurz vor der sendung aufgezeichnet
die menschen halten abstand die
gesellschaft rückt aber ein stückchen
näher zusammen und auch für die korona
krise gilt not macht erfinderisch viele
wie sich gefragt haben wie sie dass sie
jetzt tun können um zu helfen haben
kreative antworten gefunden
beide fütterungen der erdmännchen im
tierpark se hof ist gregor wilhelm
gerade alleine
der park ist dicht die mitarbeiter zu
hause finanziell eine katastrophe bis
gestern
wenn sie nah und christiane haben in
ihrer facebook mutti gruppe eine
spendenaktion gestartet der erfolg
sensationell über 86.000 euro
der tierpark darf dem virus nicht zum
opfer frei ich fand das total
faszinierend zu sehen wie viele leute
wirklich hinter dieser tat stehen was
uns sehr berührt hat sind die ganzen
kommentare die halt in den spenden mit
drin gestanden wie toll sie den tierpark
finden und wie gern sie sowas
unterstützen
die diakonie in wiesbaden muss umdenken
nicole nelles und alice krone versorgen
obdachlose weil ihre räume schließen
mussten ist der kleine transporter jetzt
eine rollende teeküche sie kommen zu
denen die hilfe brauchen normalerweise
ist es umgekehrt die menschen auf der
straße trifft die krise besonders hart
die alleine auf der straße sitzen und im
ganzen völlig schutzlos ausgeliefert
sind denn die meisten haben keine masken
meisten haben keine schule die meisten
rang 1 der kollektionen für
hilfsprojekte überall wo es kurz ist
busunternehmer in watt lassen
aber weil busreisen ja gerade nicht
stattfinden ist er eben lieferant
gemeinsam mit der stadtverwaltung und
einem supermarkt hat er eine bestell
hotline eingerichtet für quarantäne
kunden die zu hause bleiben müssen
geliefert wird dreimal pro woche die
nachfrage riesig werner druck ist
stammkunde geworden weil ich mich nicht
traue in den großen geschäfte einzugehen
das ist mir zu gefährlich die leute
halten sich in der region ist sie an die
vorschriften in wadgassen überlegen sie
sogar den lieferdienst dauerhaft
einzurichten
man erlebt wirklich jetzt kontaktpflege
oder auch seine kommunikation die
vielleicht auch ein bisschen die letzten
jahre in vergessenheit geraten ist
die korona krise verbietet enge kontakte
und verbindet trotzdem viel engagement
das ist ohne die korona krise nicht
gegeben hätte was bleibt davon nach der
krise
darüber möchte ich mit dem
zukunftsforscher matthias horx
sprechender wird jetzt per skype
zugeschaltet ist guten abend herr ochs
guten abend sie sagen nach der krise
wird nichts mehr so sein wie zuvor und
meinen das im positiven sinne
wie wird sich unsere gesellschaft in
ihrer meinung nach verändern also ein
teil ist sicher dass wir alle ja eine
ganz erstaunliche erfahrung machen dass
wir in dieser sozialen an in
anführungsstrichen isolation eigentlich
sehr gesellschaftlich werden dass wir
uns wieder sehr intensiv um uns selbst
und unseren nächsten aber auch unsere
fernbeziehungen kümmern also wir
telefonieren viel mehr
wir sind intensive im sozialen geworden
und wir erfahren gleichzeitig eben auch
gesellschaft wieder als ein gemeinsames
bestreben nicht also das ist ja das was
verloren gegangen ist man hat ja das
gefühl gehabt gesellschaften also ein
allgemeines hauen und stechen
gegeneinander
in dem kampf gegen das virus verein wir
uns ein stück weit wieder und meine
these ist dass menschen sich so was
merken
das geht das heißt nicht dass es in
derselben intensität so weitergeht aber
es erzeugt eben auch eine neue struktur
einen neuen lernprozess die hirne gehen
gewissermaßen auf wie lernt wieder dinge
die wir verlernt hatten auch im alltag
wir kochen zusammen also wir tun dinge
die im grunde genommen zum menschsein
dazu gehören und die moderne
beschleunigte gesellschaft uns ein stück
weit entfernt hat es gibt ja aber auch
negativer zukunftsprognosen angst vor
einer tiefen rezession zum beispiel oder
angst vor dem erstarken von
rechtspopulisten
was macht sie so sicher dass die welt
nicht auch eine schlechtere werden
könnte also die frage ist ja auch wir
uns doch immer von unseren engsten
treiben lassen oder von unseren
beobachtungen und von den
wahrscheinlichkeiten und wir können ja
auch feststellen dass die populisten im
grunde genommen zwar immer noch da sind
auch die die hasser und neider und die
spalte im netz die trotz die sind ja
auch immer noch da aber es wird eben
keine mehr zu weil natürlich in einer
gesellschaft enthält die nach einem
konsens sucht nach einer
gemeinschaftlichen antwort auf eine
gefahr auf eine eine krise eben da ist
das bedürfnis nach spaltung eben nicht
mehr besonders groß
was raten sie menschen die gerade große
angst davor haben dass die korona krise
unser leben nachhaltig verändern könnte
die das eben nicht so positiv sehen
können wie sie ich möchte nur darauf
hinweisen dass wir in dieser krise auch
etwas ganz seltsam ist etwas wunderbares
erlebt haben nämlich dass viele von uns
dachten jetzt bricht die welt zusammen
jetzt was jetzt passiert das
allerschlimmste aber die welt ist ja
immer noch da und sie hält und wir
machen plötzlich erfahrung die darauf
hinweisen dass vielleicht nicht immer
unsere schlimmsten erwartungen dann
tatsächlich auch eintreten
und ich glaube das ist eine sehr hohe
chance eine sehr hohe wahrscheinlichkeit
gibt es diese krise auch als eine
bewältigung erfahren wird ja wir haben
sind mit einer großen herausforderung
als zivilisation konfrontiert aber wir
können das auch schaffen wir können das
auch bewältigen und das macht menschen
stark vielen dank herr ochs für das
gespräch
das interview haben wir vor der sendung
aufgezeichnet und das war es von diesem
zdf spezial immer auf dem laufenden
bleiben sie online
zdf heute oder über die neue cd erfreute
app ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen
abend
tschüss
[Musik]